κάμαμε κάποιες αναπρος αρμογέσεις στα πλάναμας εβάλαμα κάποιες γεοτρίσεις μέσα και εκαταφέραμε να δώσουμε κάποιες
επιπλέον πως ότηται στο καλοκαίιο που μας επέρασε το σεπθεύρι νε φιλοξενίσαμε τη μέται μια
που είχε αντικείμενων τη ληψηντρία και πως επηρειάζει των πρωτογενητομέαν και από κει εξεκίνησε με
την προεργασία που κάνομε φυσικάλιο τους προηγούμενους μήνες ένας πολλά σημαντικός κύκλως η επαφών σε
επίπεδο βριξελών τόσο νεγώσον και υπόλπε ο κτο συνάδελφι τμετενια θέτον το σουσιαστικά το θέμα
νερών και πρωτογενίς τομέα στην πρώτη γραμμή και σήμερα έχουμε διυχάριστα ότι είναι και στοστο
ώραμμα το νέου επιτρόπου και δουλεύκουμε μπάνω του γι εμίσοε το περιοχόμενο απλώς για να
κλείσω των κύκλο μεταβήματα εκεί ακριβώς στη μέται μια είχαμε την ευκαιρί να έχουμε των
επίτροπο μαζί μας των τότε επίτροπο γεορικίας των ενημερώσαμε ξανάγετα τηδία για τα προβλήματα και
αποτέλεσματούτων τος συζητήσιων και ο επαφών η κύπρος κατάφερε να έχει ένα φαγελογήνω στα δεκαπεντέμιση
εκατομύρια σήμερα ως μιας μια πρώτη από ζημείωση ενοείται υκάλαμε το επενδηδικό μας στο καλοκαίρι
και το πεδητικώ που έρχεται τώρα με μόνιμες υποδομένες για τους γεοργούσμος που μιώνοντις ανάγκαις
σε νερών και βοηθά τους στο αναντάπεξέλθουμε έυπνα συστηματα άρδευψες ακολούθησε μετά αντιοτός σεπθεύρι το
πρόγραμμα κοσι οκτώ δράσιων που είναι ουσιαστικά όλοη μας ιστρατηγική και ο τρόπος που θα
πορευτούμε στην απεξάρτηση από τις καιρικές στη θεήκες ένα πρόγραμμα που ίδη ηλοποιείται και εαπό
κει ξεκινά ή εφαρμογέλον τω δεράσιω στόφος μας εμβληματικές μας δράσεις υναιι επιπλέων δύο μόνη
μες αφαλατώσεις και τεξερις κινητές δεφτανει όμως που δε βρέχει έχουμε και πλωπροβληματικά φράγματα υπάρχει
λύση σε αυτό καιαξινε τα φράγματα στην κύπρον τα περισσότερα έχουν